like I know what I'm going to tell my
kids when they get into a certain age I
I really am like I have it down about
religion and and people really
narcissists sociopaths all of this type
of stuff like you want to see a great
case thing on like narcissism Liberals
are so stupid the way that they handle
Trump you think he'd go away you know I
think he was I think he was a one hit
wonder uhhuh right he wrote The Twist
and then that was it he was on the
casino circuit and then you idiot
liberals wrote him twist again when you
indicted him and now he's a Marty he's
coming back Jimmy it's going to be great
for comedy he's coming
back that is the key thing that is
happening with the Trump situation right
now they all need him for business they
can say they hate him but if you turn on
MSNBC at any point during the day
they're talking about Trump you turn on
CNN any time of the day they're talking
about Trump you turn on any of these
late night quote unquote comedy shows
they are talking about Trump